la décision du tribunal correctionnel
est tombée cet après midi il a condamné
neuf des dix prévenus accusés d'être des
passeurs d'immigrés clandestins haïtiens
les neuf coupables vont purger une peine
d'un an à quatre ans de prison les faits
remontent à 2019 pendant des mois ces
individus ont monté un réel trafic en
bande organisée les clandestins haïtiens
arrivés de la dominique par bateau dans
des conditions souvent périlleuses
paient 400 euros la traversée jusqu'au
prêcheur puis 200 euros le transport à
une maison dont la chambre parfois
insalubres coûter 400 euros pour
l'avocat de la partie civile la décision
est forte mais d'autres réseaux
continuent toujours attirés par l'appât
du gain
les personnes qui ont été condamnées
bon on participer effectivement en tout
cas pour ceux qui ont dit la justice à
un trafic
mais dans des proportions qui laisse
penser que d'autres personnes à d'autres
endroits sont aussi concernés par ce
dossier parmi les neuf condamnés il y a
deux dominique est également frappée
d'une interdiction définitive du
territoire français tous n'ont pas
encore annoncé s'ils feront appel de la
décision